hmm you thought you had to wait a while
to DMV oh that was terrible
moving on hey overdue Doctor Who review
time and we have arrived at the girl who
waited I really like this episode I like
it a lot I feel like this is one of
those episodes that really should get
brought up more in terms of really
strong episodes especially if you're
gonna talk about Amy specifically and
I'm not gonna say never comes up but I
feel like it Rouge would come up a heck
of a lot more than it does so this is
the one where the simple mistake just
pushing a different button separates Amy
from the doctor and Rory in completely
different time streams and as the dark
nori tried to rescue her well they
missed by 36 years and amy is ticked and
then trying to figure out well how do we
rescue her oh we can rescue young Amy
but then old Amy doesn't want them to
because that means she doesn't get to
exist at all and she doesn't take the
view that oh well everything will be
great
she's taking she takes the view of that
means I die and I'm not cool with that
which oh like how cool is that like
every other time that I can think this
kind of scenario happened where somebody
has a has an event or a new or is
abandoned for a long period of time and
in a sci-fi or fantasy setting if they
have the chance to have that undone and
you know have a different path at an
earlier point in their life they're
pretty much always game for it they're
like yeah
yeah cuz I don't want what I had and the
other and the younger me can do
something else for her to be not only
not wanted but to be so adamant that's
cool
also consistent with her character like
this is just a great showcase for Amy
and a great showcase for karen gillan
there's a ton of really subtle things
that she does in the performance as old
Amy and the makeup works I'm glad they
went subtler with it they could have
gone much more severe especially given
how much time has passed and how old she
is now supposed to be I mean she's got
to be dang close to 60 um but they went
more subtle with the makeup which was
good because it doesn't bury what she is
doing acting wise under latex and makeup
um but there are just little things
about the way she looks particularly at
Rory and the way she speaks she's got a
little bit more of a sort of a
background grasp a little bit of a growl
a little bit of age to her voice and
it's really cool that that that is in
there and it man Rory in this
I love how justifiable Rory's anger at
the doctor at several points in this is
and honestly I would say Amy's anchors
pretty justified as well and it would
have been very easy to just completely
be on their side and be like the doctor
ruined everything but then there's that
carrot of we can get young Amy and we
can keep this from happening and you
kinda want that too even though it
completely screws over old Amy and also
kind of Rory like this kind of breaks
him having to do this what happens at
the end and the man that moment that
moment at the end where old Amy sees the
doctors face and realizes he's not gonna
let her in the TARDIS
all he can do is say I'm sorry and close
the door and then Rory comes over you
know starts berate him and the doctor
does I think what might be the most
cowardly thing that the doctor has ever
done which is to say to Rory
fine you choose because they can't both
exist I know I said they could but they
can't I lied because I was trying to get
this fixed and I needed them to believe
me I needed you to believe me
but we can't have both so you don't want
me to choose fine you choose and it's a
dick move but it's also an
understandable one because the doctor he
spent this entire story basically being
berated by Rory and two different
versions of Amy's for failing and not
being any good at this and he kind of
throws it back and Rory's face and says
fine you make the call then what will
you do since you don't trust me to make
these decisions anymore and under other
circumstances it would run the risk of
breaking the doctor as a character but
it again much like with the little
things done with Amy's performance and
how her anger feels rooted in character
rather than feeling like contrived drama
the doctor's cowardice in handing the
decision over to Rory knowing that it
was not a cool thing for him to do does
feel consistent with this doctor because
he has his moments Smith does of
basically just kind of snapping he
doesn't always turn on a dime but when
he when the straw breaks the camel's
back he can be nasty and that happens
here and it gets directed at the
companions which hasn't happened
hun in new who usually when the doctor
snaps it gets directed at some enemy and
boom boy they better get out of the way
but here he's got no one to snap at
except Rory and when old Amy and Rory
are on either side of the TARDIS door
rewatching that this time that was rough
in the best way because she loves him so
much and he can't disconnect he can't
say well that's not my Amy this is and
so I don't have to feel the same thing I
feel for her he he sees everything you
loved about Amy in this older version
and the pain that both of them express
in that and with Amy being honest that
she wants in like she's not just they
they balance this really well she's not
just saying she never tells him it's
okay she never tells him I accept this
because she doesn't but she's still
honest with him and says you should not
let me in but that's not her accepting
her fate
that's her just not lying to her husband
and there was something about old Amy
when she says how Rory when younger Amy
gets knocked out and he picks her up and
he carries her into the TARDIS and old
Amy says the way you looked at her you
used to look at me like that
and really hammering the idea that this
is a unique person who's had a unique
life and a unique perspective separate
from the Amy that has been rescued and
that this person is now going to die it
makes it feel like a loss
that's really really good that said I do
have some nitpicks
about this but they are relatively minor
but they do kind of stick in my craw a
little bit because the emotional
resonance and the performances and the
core concept Wow
love it however first of all the hand
robots they kind of annoy me I get that
they're not meant to actually be a
security force so it kind of makes sense
that they're not that hard to defeat but
they're so easy to knock out that it
actually kind of annoys me it's actually
towards the very end when Rory Schwartz
went out by busting of picture over its
head like not even the frame just the
cam but it just puts his head through
the canvas and that shorts it out like
really making them seem that weak and
it's okay that they're not unstoppable
or they shouldn't be and they overwhelm
with numbers and that's fine but like it
doesn't quite work in terms of them
trying to hit the balance on that other
stuff they Val's perfectly back not so
much and the other thing is they kind of
I feel they kind of cheat and use the
passage of a significant amount of time
to gloss over I'm sorry Amy made her own
sonic screwdriver and reprogrammed an
advanced piece of alien AI I'm sorry
what and it's not an uncommon sort of
trope it happens in a lot of fiction
especially sci-fi fantasy fiction when a
character is isolated for long enough
that it's basically implied oh well they
just picked up these skills in order to
survive and a lot of things tend to cash
that check for a bit more than it's
worth I think this does here because
look the human race hasn't invented
anything close to a sonic screwdriver
and now gran didn't like she's been
around it she kind of knows how it
handles but that's that's too much of a
leap I mean I'm not trying to
shortchange her but you know I Drive a
car every day if you put me in a
scenario where I it would be helpful for
me to use a car but I don't have one
I couldn't build one from scratch even
if I had 36 years and it's a bit of a
leap for me that Amy could build that
and similarly with hacking the interface
I'm like really and I get maybe part of
his because she's just never shown that
particular skill set or acumen it's not
that I don't think Amy's not smart
enough to be able to do this stuff but
she hasn't been shown to have that
particular set of skills or that kind of
aptitude like if her messing around with
the tech stuff was a thing that like she
did more regularly like on her own not
like the doctor hands or something and
she uses it but like she's she kind of
pokes around and goes oh and and like
figures out the technical nuts and bolts
then yes I could maybe make that leap
but she doesn't really not in any
significant way that I can think of and
it makes that a little bit
hard for me to swallow not to the point
that it breaks and I don't buy the
narrow the narrative but you know that's
a lot to gloss over that's a that's a
big leap you're asking us to make but
again I don't consider these to be major
issues because the emotional work and
the core thing in the relationship and
the thematics of it are so good yeah I
these things bug me but they only bug me
a little and certainly in the heat of
watching it I'm like yeah that's all
annoying but
there's a good bit I kind of have that
go on a lot the girl who waited what do
you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something on down in
the comments let's talk about it there's
a bunch of stuff to do as well you know
the stuff likes subscribe share this
check out the patreon hey that's a
thought
plus other links for other things
besides but you also don't have to do
any of it I mean this links you down
there below but at the end of the day
folks you're the council and I'm just
running the meetings and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]